okay uh today uh we are going to see
uh data-driven testing uh using database
as a source
so what is data-driven testing so
yesterday we have seen like we can
specify the test data in
a file which can be or excel or it can
be database
and we read the data from the source
file and we use the data to perform the
data driven testing right
so in the previous session we have seen
how to work with excel uh excel sheet
like how to write the data into excel
how to read the data from excel and how
we can perform the data driven testing
using excel as a data file
and we have used
some third party or
open by excel right so open by excel is
an api which is
installed and then we will able to work
with excel sheet
so now similarly uh to work with the
database also
so we need to install something called
uh mysql connector okay so because we
have to connect to the database
and we have to execute the queries
through our program okay so for that we
need to have a
mysql excel connector so it depends on
the database so whichever database you
are working we need to install that
particular
uh
that particular module we can say okay
so first of all we'll see what is that
and uh
then we will see how we can interact
with the database first we will see some
basic operations like how to connect to
the database then how we can work with
the table like how we can insert the
data in the table how we can retrieve
the data from the table and how we can
update the data how we can delete the
data from a table so we need to ever
offer these basic
operations on the database through
automation code okay
and once you understand this then we
will see finally how we can fetch the
data from the database and how we can
use the data to perform the data driven
testing
right
so now we'll see how we can work with
the database so as a prerequisite the
first thing is
you need to install a database okay a
mysql you can install mysql because it
is open source
and instead of going with oracle or
mysql server so we can just uh
easily install my sql because sql
statements almost same in every database
so you cannot see much difference
and
even the program whatever we are writing
in the program so that is also exactly
the same
and the same code works for every kind
of database
and but only thing is uh the connector
will be changed so whatever the
connector we are going to install now
for mysql the same connector may not
work for other databases so we need to
install oracle connector
and
my sql connector different connectors
are there so we need to install them in
pi champ and then we will able to
interact with the particular databases
okay
now first of all
as a prerequisite you need to have my
sequel on your system okay so if you
don't have you have to download it and
you have to install it first
and once you install your my sql server
on your local machine
so then we need to log into mysql and
you need to create a database we need to
create a some sample table and you need
to populate some data in the table so
all these things you have to do as a
prerequisite to work with the databases
in python
okay so if you are not aware of sql or
if you are not aware of how to download
and how to install mysql and how to set
up my sql how to create the database how
to create the table so if you want to
know all these things
i'll share some videos recorded videos
link
and you can just go to the link and i
have explained the complete my sequel
concepts this particular playlist you
can get it from my youtube channel okay
but it is very important okay it is not
only for automation even if you go with
automation testing interview so people
will ask
questions from the database definitely
they will ask questions from the
database
so here i have just created almost 16
videos
so i can just go through each and every
video step by step and you can just
practice it your own
okay so again this is very huge concept
database i'm not going to cover here so
i just provide this link in the notes
and i provided here so go through the
link and from the beginning like what is
the introduction of database dbms
everything and then mysql like how to
install my sql how to work with the
color sql workbench command line so many
things are there and at least if you
listen first three videos you will be
able to work with the automation okay
first three videos at least you have to
know
like how to set up my sequel and how to
connect to the client and how to create
a database table in certain records
retrieving the data so at least uh first
three videos so you have to listen you
have to watch them and you have to do it
practically
and the rest of them you can just
prepare later also but to proceed
further for automation testing at least
we need to know uh these three concepts
okay
now listen this so let me just i already
copied this link and you can guy i can
get this link from this notes and you
can practice it
okay
now so let me just uh reference
reference link so this is mandatory
required guys so database is most
important
this is a reference link my sequel
reference link
okay so now how to work with the
database so first of all we will see
uh through automation code so let me
just show you some basic operation the
database so i already have my sql on my
machine so let me just connect to the my
sequel so if i take any database
right so there are two different uh
components are there
one is called as a
database server you can call as a
database server
the other component is database client
database client
so what is database server and what is
the database client
so normally the database server is
actual location where actual data will
be stored in the form of tables
all the databases are there in the
database server actual database server
is installed on that machine
and database client is a software a
small software through which we will be
able to connect to the database
from different location
so normally in the real time what
happens is you will not install
databases on your local machines okay so
databases will always install on the
remote machines but most of the times
on the linux machine so the databases
will be installed
so let us say this is my database server
and this is my database server and here
all the data will be stored
and uh
number of people uh will use the
database server so let us say this is
one
engineer he's another engineer so from
their local laptops they can connect to
the remote databases and uh then they
can access the database basically so
they can do all operation from their
local machines
but actually they don't install the
database server but without database
without installing database server in
those local machines how we can how can
they access the database server so these
people will install database clients in
every mission they will install only
client software
there are so many client softwares are
available in the market
so if i just go to mysql we have
sql workbench is a default lines okay
you will get automatically if you
install database server
and if you go with oracle we have sql
developer is there sql plus is there and
code is there
right so and if you go with the ms sql
server so we have sql server management
studio is there so for every database
there are so many client softwares are
available so you can use any client
software
so by default if you install database
server by default you will get the
client
okay by default you will get the client
if you install database server because
at the time of installing the database
it will ask you so do you want install
only database server or do you
want to install a database server along
with the client
or do you want to install only the
client so which will ask you at the time
of installation
so accordingly we have to select
depends upon your requirement and then
we will install the software
but in the real environment normally
what happens is all the databases will
be there in the remote machines
and people who want to work with the
databases they will given some access
and they will provide you the database
administrators will be there so they
will provide access like they will
provide you username and password
database name port number all these
things so accordingly
while connecting the database using
client so in the client you have to
provide those connection details
and how client will connect to the
database here by using connection
details which will connect to the
database and then once your client
application is connected to the database
then we will work all the stuff in the
database like we can review the data
from a table we can create the table in
the database server we can delete update
all kinds of operations we can perform
on the database through this client
application
okay so this is how things will happen
so mainly in the databases there are so
many commands are there
like if this is a database server and
travis client is basically database
server is a place where exactly all the
data will be stored because
a database server needs a lot of space
okay normally the machines are having
higher configuration machines they will
use to install database server but your
client machine may not have that
configuration so that kind of use
configuration so you will just install
only client software it is very
lightweight software
through which you will be able to
connect to the database server
but uh if you install mysql database on
your local machine by default you will
get database server along with the
client
okay these are the two important things
which you need to understand
now
what is an sql
so what is an sql so we understood what
is database server what is a database
client so database server is an area
where exactly data will be stored
database client is a software through
which we are able to connect to the
database server
and we can execute all the queries only
through database client
so query is nothing but a statement okay
by which we will work with the database
and what is an sql here
sql is a structure query language
and this is the language by which we
will able to communicate with the
database if you want to work with the
database
database will understand a language
right so what is that language sql so if
you go with any kind of database like
oracle sql server mysql everywhere sql
is almost same so if i learn sql from
one database you can easily work with
any other databases
if you learn sql from mysql then you
will be able to
work with the oracle sql so it is almost
same common language for all the
databases so structure query language is
a language
by which we will able to communicate
with the database but how why we will
communicate with the database because we
want to create a tables we want to
insert the data in the table we want to
update the data we want to select the
data so we will do so many operations on
the database so to perform all these
operations we have to communicate with
the database through a language so that
is a sequel structure query language
okay so in the database server actual
databases are installed all the
databases will be created in the
database server and whichever database
you have an access so we can connect to
the database and you can
find the data which is available in the
database so sql is mandatory required
but what is an sql means sql contains so
many
uh sub languages like
uh we have uh ddl
okay so ddl we have
data definition language so here we have
certain number of commands called uh
create
alter
drop truncate and so on
and similarly we have one more command
dml command so data manipulation
language commands so here insert command
update command
and delete command this comes under the
dml data manipulation language commands
and also we have a drl data retrieval
language so select command comes under
this
select a command will comes under the
drl
and then we have a tcl transaction
control command
so we have a commit and rollback so
these are the comes under tcl
transaction control language commands
and we also have a dcl command so data
control language commands
so here we have
grant
okay and rework
so these are the commands which are
comes under dcl so learning sql in the
sense
learning all these commands
and different commands various types of
commands are there in sql
but everybody will not use every command
and most of the developers most of the
times database designers right they will
use ddl
and dml
most of the times because they are the
people
they want to create the database so they
have to populate that they have to
create the tables they have to populate
some data in it
right administrators mostly database
administrators and designers they use
these commands
more
and now
testers or we can just go with the
developers
and developers also use ddl and dml
commands
and testers will use dml and drl
commands most of the times because we
are not going to create any tables in
the database we just want to work with
the data so we want to insert the data
in the table and we will check whether
insertion is properly working or not and
updation is working or not deletion is
working or not and we are mainly test
our testing is mainly focused on the
data on the table
not on other things
as per the functional testing i'm
talking about so because database
testing is a very huge thing it's not a
simple thing okay it's a completely
completely different it's a back-end
testing so in the database
if you want to test the complete
database testing you need to you need to
focus a lot of things
like not only data you have to check the
tables and relationship of the tables
and every table you have to verify the
column types what are the data type of
the columns what is the size of the
columns
and the normalization so what are the
relationship between the tables and you
have to test the procedures so stringers
functions
so and again which includes white box
testing and blockbuster so there are so
many things we need to test as part of
the database testing which includes a
functional and non-functional
but as point of functional testing what
we will do is normally when you want to
perform database testing
so normally we do some action on the
application so let's say there is a
registration form is available on your
web page so you provide all the data and
you will submit it
and you will get some acknowledgement
message okay your data is submitted or
your registration is successfully done
and you will get some acknowledgement on
the ui
but uh is it really uh
true whether easy whether it is
successfully successfully inserted data
in the table or not how we will know
that
just by seeing the confirmation message
we cannot confirm
so we have to log into the database we
have to get the data from the particular
table or registration table and see
whether the data is available or not so
whatever data you are provided from the
ui or application the same record is
available in the database or not you
have to test this manually
so that is actual database testing we
will do as per the functional point of
view as an auto as a functional tester
and if you are purely database test
engineer then you have to focus more on
database objects how to test the tables
procedures views indexes store processor
triggers cursor there are so many things
you have to test there's completely
purely back and testing and there you
will not do anything on the application
side testing
okay so as a functional test engineer
you have to do
some testing on the web application and
some part of testing you do on the
database side so it is a combination of
front-end and backend
so that's the reason we can also call it
as a gray box testing it is not purely
white box and also it is not purely
black box so when you do the restriction
on the ui when you do testing on that
that's a black boss test
but once you log into the database and
execute the queries and see the data in
the table that is a white box testing so
the combination we can call as a gray
box so that's a completely database
testing pattern
but celium is not meant for database
testing
selenium is basically
used for automating the web that's the
main fundamental concept of cylinder
webdriver
okay most of the people will use this
technology like database testing using
selenium like this
but if i really say
by using selenium we are not exactly
testing the database
we are not exactly testing the database
but what exactly we are doing with the
database in automation is if the if you
already have some tables in the database
if it contains some data
we will read the data from the tables
and we use the data for testing purpose
and that time
we should able to interact with the
database we should connect to the
database and we will execute all the
queries through automation script
so that's how we will do that it is not
completely database testing
okay so database testing
we have to use some different tools are
available and most of the times we use
manual testing only because we don't
have automation tools for to perform the
database testing so eighty percent of
the testing will be done manually in
database testing side okay so selim is
only meant for web application it's not
meant for database testing
but still
uh we should able to interact with the
database
still we fetch the data from the tables
okay and sometimes we can insert the
data update the data so these operations
we can do through automation script
at minimum level
okay
so to do these all these things uh we
have to know the exclude so which is
very very important so as a automation
tester so we have to mainly focus on
these commands dml
drl and again in the drl select command
you have to learn joins the subqueries
right all these things set operators
union union all intersect so these are
all very important
and now tcl and dcl most of the times
developer will use it because their
transactional control language so
whenever you do insert or update delete
and those transactions will not perform
permanently so if you want to make the
transaction permanent then we have to
issue the commit command
and suppose by mistake you have done
some mistake and if you want to get back
that mistake if you want to roll back
then you will use rollback command
and grant and rework is used by the
administrator if the administrator want
to give some permission to the user on
the tables or on the database they use
grant command
and if they want to remove the
permissions they use revoke command
so various commands are there so in my
videos i have explained all the commands
in depth so i can just go to the videos
and learn sql in depth okay that is how
i can recommend as of now okay
so
this much knowledge is enough to proceed
with the automation
so now
by default as i said selenium is a web
automation so which we cannot interact
with any database
we cannot do anything on the database by
using selenium
but uh yesterday also we have same thing
we discussed
psyllium doesn't support excel but how
you have interacted with excel how you
have worked with excel in automation
we have externally we have installed
open by excel
and then we got some classes and methods
through which we will able to do that
same thing for database also
for database also we have to install
proper connector
depends upon type of database and then
we will get some classes and methods
and by using those classes and methods
we will be able to work with the
databases
okay now we'll see step by step so the
first thing is we need to as a
prerequisite we need to install
something called
mysql
connector for python
so this is a package which we have to
install on pycharm and which will
provide you so many classes and methods
so through which we will be able to
interact with the database but before
directly going to the automation part
let me show you manually so i said i
already have my sql software on machine
so i already have one client also let me
just open my client my sql workbench is
my client application so i'm just
opening it
so once you open this application so
your client will be open and through
that client we will be able to connect
to the database
and whenever you want to connect to the
database you have to know the connection
details
even if you connect to manually or even
if you want to connect through
automation you have to know the
connection details of the database
so normally a database administrators
will provide you the connection details
through which you will able to connect
so i already saved my connection so if
you want to connect to the database from
the my sequel workbench
this is a manual process i just showing
you so here we need to take the database
and connect to database and here you can
just look at here
we need to provide the connection
details
so currently my escrows my sql is
available in my local machine itself so
i'm just providing the host name
127.0.0 is representing your local
mission
and if you don't know the iep you can
directly write a local host
and in the real environment so they will
provide you ip address of the machine so
you can provide the ip address of the
machine or name of the mission whatever
they provide you have to specify inside
the host name
and the second field is a port number so
every database will run on some port
number
if it is my sequel it will be 3306 if it
is oracle it can be one five two one or
one five two seven
okay and similarly if you go with mysql
server or any other databases they will
use some default port numbers
and uh on that particular port number
that are the database will run so here
you have to provide the username
and if there is a password you can also
provide the password
and at the time of installation i have
not provided i guess so
i think i have also password but i have
already saved the password in the store
involved so it is not asking for the
password every time
and as soon as you click on this ok so
which will able to connect to the
database
so it will automatically connect to the
now we can just look at here so as soon
as you open the database by default you
will see like this
so you will get by default some
databases like classic models my classic
models
cycle rcs world
okay so my flicks db so there are some
databases by default you will get along
with the mysql
so apart from that if you want to use
existing databases still you can use it
and which is also having some default
tables and here you can see customer
info is there
and in the world also there are some
tables are there city country jobs
location there are multiple tables are
there so like this every database is
having some default tables and if you
want to create your own database again
you can create your own database and you
can create your own tables and you can
populate some data in the table by
writing insert commands
so these are all prerequisites guys so
i'm not going to show you all these
things because it will take a lot of
time to explain these things so
go through the videos and you will
understand everything so i explained
everything in my videos okay how to
create the database how to create the
table how to insert the data in the how
to insert the sample data in the table
how to query the data from the table so
all the commands have explained uh in
sequentially so can go through them and
understand
now here in my db there are multiple
tables are there
okay so inside this i have one table
called student table i have
so i want to see the data of the student
table
so then i just want to open the sql
editor
and if i click on the corner icon this
will give an editor
so here i have to write a query or
statement by which we will able to
interact with the table so before
interacting the table you have to
connect to the database further we can
say use command use my db
so because there are so many databases
are there here on which db you want to
interact so we need to specify so i say
my db
so first command you have to execute
this and here the run option is there
when i execute this now it is currently
pointing to my db my db insert this what
does the table have here
i have one table called uh
i have one table called student so let
me ping the data so i say select
star
from student
and semicolon so when i execute this
command
this will give you the data which is
already available in the student table
so currently have only three records and
two columns so sies and s so these are
tables so like this we can print the
data from any table by using select a
command
so select is a retrieval command we can
retrieve the data from the database
right so this is a client application
and i already connected to the database
and i can you can see all the tables
which are already available and
whichever table data you want to see you
can just execute select star star means
what all the columns you will get
and if you want to get only specific
column specify the column name and
execute you will get only that specific
column so when i say star
which will match with all the columns
and display all the columns data here
[Music]
okay
so this is how we can just work with the
client applications
now
whatever suppose i want to insert the
new record in this table so then i have
to write insert query like this insert
into
so insert into
our table name is student and values
and here you have to specify let's say
one zero four
and a comma some x y z like this so you
have to specify that
i even execute this which will go and
insert the new record in the table
similarly if i want update so you can do
one more command
so
sql is not a case sensitive language you
can write all the queries in this
lowercase or uppercase characters
so update
student table
and what we need to update suppose i
want to update
uh 103 record with a different name i
want to change the name of the 103
record
so i can say update student set s id
offset s name
set s name
equal to
uh so and so let's say abc
and uh if i stop command like this what
happens which will update s name abc
with all the records
all the records i simply say update
student sets s name equal to abc means
which will update all the records but i
want to update only one zero three
record so we have to put one where
condition so where s id equal to 1 0 3
so when i execute this command which
will go and update the recording the
table directly
but
here i have it i'll i can get i can
execute all this command through client
here
but that's not my requirement i should
able to execute these commands through
my python code or python program
right so that's a our intention but
before that just for understanding
purpose i have shown you how to connect
to the client
and how to
represent the database and how to
execute the queries from the client
application
okay but all these things we are going
to do through python code
that's our intention okay
now let me just minimize it
now go back to the pie chart
so now we are going to first before
discussing about data driven testing we
have to know first we have to install
this connector and after that i'll show
you
a few operations like database
operations
database operations so mainly i will
focus on three commands
because we are not going to create or
delete all these things because there
are ddl commands
they will work on the tables not data so
mainly database operations will like
insertion
insert command
update
and delete
so these are the main database
operations along with the selector okay
select also we can use
so these are the four commands i'm going
to discuss
through python code how we can execute
these commands or how we can execute
this queries to python code so as a
prerequisite first of all we need to
install this
package
and if you are working with oracle then
the package will be different
okay
now go back to the pi champ
and how to install the package
so to install it we need to go to the
file again settings so all the packages
we have to install only here okay from
this location so go to your project
python interpreter now you can just look
at there are so many packages we already
installed earlier open by excel is also
there seal name is also there right and
uh now we are going to install
mysql connector so here just type mysql
so when i say my sql so you can see this
one connector mysql
connector iphone python so what is this
mysql driver written in python
okay so this is the connector we have to
install so just select it and click on
install package
and because i already installed this so
this is given in the blue color in your
case you can just select it
and then click on install package and
within the few seconds it will go and
install it and after closing this window
you will able to see the mysql connector
in this list
okay so once you have done this you can
just close a window now
you are ready to connect to the database
and you are ready to work with the
database tables
all right now let me show you the script
file first let me just create another
another directory
and
i say day 25
so before going to discuss actual data
driven testing we need to know
basic stuff like how to interact with
the database how can execute the queries
these things are very much required
all right so let me just create
a new python file
so i'll name it as uh db operations
db operations
now as soon as you created a file you
want to do the database operation so in
this insertion
and then update and then
delete so select i will show you in
another example
okay so because
there is a difference between these
commands so when i when i execute insert
update delete command it will go and
execute against the database and perform
the insertion updation and deletion
that's it only these commands will work
only one direction
but when you execute the select command
what happens the select command will
execute against the table and fetch the
data and also data will be returned
but rest of three commands will not
return anything for you it will just go
and update the data or it will just go
and insert the data or it will go and
just delete the data but the select is
not like that
when execute the select command which
will go and fetch the data from the
database table and return the data also
so we need to use some special classes
to hold the data and everything
so select is something different than
rest of three commands so let us see
first these three commands insert update
delete
go back
to the pi champ
so first we will see these three
commands so first of all what we need to
do is
so
we need to first import the mysql
connector model so how to import it
using import
say mysql
import mysql
dot
connector
okay so this is a package which we have
to import first step
now the second step
first we need to establish the
connection to the database so how to
establish the connection to the database
so we need to know the connection
details
details like database
iep port number user password database
all these things we have to do
so to connect to the mysql database what
we need to do is we will
have one method inside the
mysql.connector
dot
there is a method called connector okay
this is a method and uh this particular
connect method will connect to the
database based on the connection details
which we provided but how to provide the
connection details exactly we follow the
syntax so what is the syntax we have to
specify the multiple parameters
so host name is localhost
localhost or ip address also we can
specify if a database is there in the
remote machines
and then port
number and a username password and
database name because there are multiple
databases are there so i just want to
work with the mydb so i've just provided
mydb here and user is a root and
password is also root i'm given
so these username and password you will
provide at the time of installation the
same username and password you can still
use it
so now by using these details and these
are the keywords host is a keyword port
is a keyword user is a keyword password
is also keyword database is also keyword
you should not change them
so by using this connection details
this particular connect method will
connect to the database
and we will store that connection in a
variable i'll create one variable called
con
and which is representing a connection
object so basically which will return a
connection object after successful
correction is happen
and that connection
we are going to store here
so normally what happens is let's say
this is my database
and this is my python code here i'm
writing the python code and our python
code is acting as a client
okay our python code is acting as a
client now because we are connecting
through python code we are sending all
queries through python code so our
python code is acting as a client
so before working with the database we
have to establish the connection between
these two so the connection is
established by using this command
and what is the next thing we have to do
we have to
create a statement first we have to
create one statement or we have to
create one query and that statement we
have to execute
we have to execute through this
connection
okay so we have to execute this
statement through this connection but we
cannot directly execute this statement
through this connection
so we have to create something called
cursor which is a basically a buffer
area or temporary memory we can say
so what you will do is with this
connection we will create a cursor
and through this cursor we will execute
the statement
okay so let me just show you step by
step process so here
so
once again
so this is a connection we have
established and we created one cursor
right and through this cursor we have to
call one method called executor
so through this execute method we will
able to execute the statement insertion
command
so what the statement will do this will
go and insert the record in the table
and as soon as this transaction is done
so insertion updation deletion
everything is a transaction right
as soon as we executed any dml command
the transaction will not be permanently
available so the transaction will not be
permanent
but we need to commit the transaction so
whenever you execute any dml commands we
have to execute a commit command
immediately otherwise the transaction
data will not be permanent in the table
so for that i can execute one more
command
okay and
by using connection object i can execute
commit
there is a connect commit command so
this command will make the
commit the transaction so basically this
particular statement will create a
cursor
and this particular statement will exude
a query through cursor
and
this particular command will commit the
transaction
and once we have done it our job is over
then finally whatever connection we have
opened here we have to close the
connection connection dot
close
that's it only five lines of code
so this is the beauty of the python so
if you want to write the same program in
java at least 20 lines of code we have
to write 20 plus lines of code we have
to write in java
so here it is very very simple so just
we establish the connection to the
database and we created the cursor which
is actually temporary memory through
that we have executed the insert query
and commit the transaction and close the
connection
and after that i will just print some
confirmation message i say print
i say finished
over
let's execute and see what will happen
so currently in the table i have only
three records
now i'm executing this code and see what
happens when executing this
so completely done finished now can go
back to the client
and uh you can execute the statement
select star from student and see
the new record is inserted in the table
so we have not inserted through this
client okay so we have not executed
these commands here we have executed
insert command through python code from
here
okay so insertion is successfully done
similarly we can just change the query
here same code for updation deletion
selection everything whatever command
you want to execute you can just keep
that command statement or sql statement
inside this double quotation and that is
the command which is automatically
execute against the database
so now i'm going to show you
update and delete operation so instead
of writing this whole query here
what i will do is i will just create all
the query statements here
okay so i will name it as
insert underscore query i'm just giving
some name to this insert underscore
query so this insert query i will
specify here
okay so instead of writing the whole
statement
and similarly i will write one more
statement for update query update query
i'm just storing the queries in some
other variables
instead of writing the whole thing every
time in this box okay so update query if
you want to update the record what is
the command we have to execute
this is a command
so i will put in the double quotations
and store this so update student set s
name
so previously what is the name of the
104 kim is there
kim is a name right so i want to just
change the name of the 104 record
so what i can do is i can simply say
meri okay so
update student set test name equal to
mary
it can be a single quote or mostly it is
single quote
because double quotations inside the
double quotations are not allowed so
single quotation where sed equal to one
zero
four
because one zero four only we want to
update so
update s name
mary
whose s id is one zero four
now go back and this is update query so
now i want to execute update query
through this program just install insert
query just i'm changing update query
same thing again connection will open
cursor will create execute the statement
commit the transaction close the
connection finished
so now execute so previously we have
kim 104 record is a kim
now
execute this
and after completion now we can go back
and see the select star from student
now the 104 is updated as a mary
so like this we can execute the update
commander
now i want to remove the records not
only the one zero four you can work with
any uh records
and you can just update one zero one
also one zero two one zero three or
similarly you can delete any record
okay so now i want to delete fourth
record one zero four record so then i
can write one more query delete
underscore query
equal to
and how to delete the specific record
from the database
so this is a query we have to write i
say delete
from
table name students
student where we have to specify
sid equal if i just leave the command
till here what will happen
delete from student which will delete
all the records from the table
but i don't want to delete all the
records i just want to delete only
fourth record one zero four record so we
have to put one condition where
s id equal to one zero four
so when execute this query this will go
and delete the record from the table now
i just want to execute that query
through our python code
so this semicolon is optional so we're
not required so you can just pass the
delete query here
okay so now delete query will execute so
let's execute now
so it is done so now go back
and previously we have four records now
execute this command again select star
from student
now again it becomes a one zero three so
one zero four record is got deleted
okay so this is how we can just work
with the
basic operation like insert update and
delete the data from the
tables
now when i execute this code
this is fine perfectly fine sometimes
what happen is suppose your database is
down
okay suppose your database is down
somehow database is restarting
then what happens at that time if you
run your code then what happens
so this particular statement will throw
the exceptions
because this statement only will
establish a connection to the database
at the time of connecting to the
database if the database is not
available or the database is down or
database is restarting in those
situations what happens this will throw
the exception connection error which
will return
but we we should able to handle that
even though the database is down our
program should display connection is
unsuccessful or database is down so like
that our program should display the
message instead of getting an error
okay so let me just uh uh do some wrong
uh some i just give instead of i cannot
make the database connection down but
instead what i can do is i can change
the connection details so i'll say uh
instead of 3d 0 6 i say 7
okay so connection details are wrong so
with this data there is no database
available as of now so when you run this
code what happens is which will
throw an error now we can just look at
here it will basically throw the
connection error interface error like
this no connection could be made
no connection could be made
okay so this will happen
in many scenarios sometimes your
database is down or sometimes your
database is restarting or even the
database is available your connection
details are not correct
so in those cases you may have see these
kind of issues so in that case what you
can do is
if your connection is not successful for
example
i just want to
exit my code
instead of giving an error okay i just
want to tell okay database is not
available or connection is not
established and
smoothly i want to exist from the code
so for that what you have to do
what is the concept you have to use here
to handle that
exception handling concept
exception handling concept okay now what
i'll do is i'll put the whole code
inside the try block
okay so i'll put everything inside the
try block
now if there is any exception is occur
in these statements and then by using
accept block
i will handle it
and here no need to specify any
exception just accept block will
automatically handle all kinds of
exception but here i will provide some
message to the user what is that
connection
unsuccessful
okay connection unsuccessful i just
provide some message to the user like
this
right so now observe this if i handle
this block what happens even though
sometimes your database connection is
not established your script will not
fail it will just tell you connection is
unsuccessful that's it so let me just
see some
data invalid data now you can just look
at this
it will just tell you connection is
unsuccessful
but you will not get any error like this
so when you're working with the database
connections and everything so this is
how we need to follow
okay so this is how we need to follow
so try and accept block
so with this we have seen three
different type of operations insertion
updation and deletion how to perform the
insertion
how to perform the update and delete
and not only these three command guides
so whatever commands i have listed here
all the commands we can execute
but that is not our scenario here we are
not going to work with any tables or
uh anything so that's again data
definition language the creation of the
whole creation of the database and
tables will happen
but that is not always recommend so
through the code no one will create the
tables so they will directly log into
the database and they will create
whatever the tables they require
okay but just for your understanding i'm
just telling you so all the sql commands
we can execute not only this
now
again we have to use different kinds of
syntaxes okay not directly so create
table is different syntax command is a
different syntax where you have to
specify the table name column names data
type of the columns so many things are
there
now we'll see the select command
so so far we have seen only three
command insert updated these commands
will go and execute against the database
but it will not return anything for us
but select command is not like that
which will return something for us
the data will be written from the
database table
so now i'll show you
how to work with the select command
go back
and what i'll do is i will just copy the
same code
and few changes we have to done so
instead of db operation i say
select a db operation
select db operation
now what are the changes we have to do
here is we don't need all these queries
we need only select a query
so here i'll create one query called a
select query i'm defining one variable
called select underscore query
and because you have only one select you
don't need to create this variable also
you can directly write the select query
here so if i just look at the client
application again so when executing this
command what happens this is giving the
data here right the same command i just
want to execute through automation code
because i want to execute only one
command so instead of creating a
variable i am directly specifying that
sql statement inside the execute method
okay so this is fine so it will go and
execute the select command
and
commit is required or not committee is
not required here
because this is a
not going to insert or update or delete
any data it is just return the data
whatever it is available so commit is
not required here you can just remove
the command
okay and what else we need here so we
need to do something more what is that
before closing the connection
so what this statement will do
so as soon as we executed this statement
which will return the data for us
which will return all the record from a
table right
so we have to store the records in the
variable we have to store them in a
variable
but where we will store where the data
is available
so as soon as we executed this data as
soon as we executed this command
actually the data also from where we are
executing this command through cursor
what is the cursor cursor is a buffer or
temporary area
let me just clarify what exactly it is
so normally what happens is uh
this is my database okay let's say this
is my database
okay and now here we are executing all
the queries we are executing this query
right and actually this query should go
through
the cursor this is the cursor
and again this cursor is also part of
the connection okay so this is a
temporary area so when i execute insert
command the insertion also will go
through the cursor and perform the
operation here so one direction when you
execute update and delete command also
it will go through the cursor and
execute here but when execute the select
command
that command also will go through the
cursor and whatever the data is returned
the data also will be available in the
same cursor
the returned data also available in the
so now as soon as you executed this
command the returned data also available
in the same cursor
now if you want to access this data from
where we can access
through this cursor we will be able to
access
but how much data we have in the cursor
we don't know that you can have 10
records you can have 50 records you can
have 100 cars we don't know that but i
want to read all the data from the
cursor
so how we can get that we have to write
a looping statement
okay so how to write a looping statement
we have to just get the data from the
cursors
now
so here
i say for
i define one variable called columns
in
cursor
so what exactly happened from the cursor
first it will fetch one record one row
into this column okay one row
okay so
or what we can do is instead of columns
i say row here that is a better option
row so from the cursor which will get
the first row so what is the first row
contains a side scientist name 101 and
david now those two values are available
inside this row
now we need to extract those values
independently how to extract them simply
we can say
row of
zero
and comma row of 1
okay and in the row 0 is a column number
one is another column number in the same
row so we want to print them
put them in the print statement like
this so like this if you have n number
of columns so i will also change the
table name guys because this table
contains only two records
so let me also change the table so here
go to the client
i have another table called orders so
let me just
select the star from orders
okay so now we have uh two records but
fine we have a three columns id order
number order day so i want to read all
the data
so let me just change the table name
called orders
okay now what happens from the cursor
it will get the one row and store into
that variable now the row contains the
three columns what are they id order
number order date so first row three
columns
now we need to extract one by one so row
of zero means what in that particular
row
zero column is id so row of one means
what in the same row first column which
is order number
now row
of
means what in the same row second column
so here
column values will start from 0 counting
from 0 so zero one two so we have a
three columns we say row of zero row of
one row same row zero column first
column second column once it is printed
then it will go up and get another row
into this
now again we will print that value so
like this depends upon the number of
records in a table
this particular loop statement will
repeat multiple times
so after printing all the data then
finally i'll close the connection
okay so this is the only thing we can do
that so this will close connection
all right now execute and see
yes
connection is unsuccessful why because
we have given port number wrong here so
let me correct it
let's execute one more time
yeah now we can see we got the data so
this is a
uh id and this is the order number and
this is the actually we are we cannot
get the column values header values but
we can get only data so this is the data
so even if you have 100 requests you
will get all 100 records from the table
okay so simply we have to write some
additional
to print the data from the table which
is returned so as i said
as soon as we executed this query so
select query we have executed so it will
also return the data the data also will
be stored in the same cursor so from
this cursor we want to read each
individual row and from that particular
row we have to get individual columns
like this
and this is how we need to
work with the select command
okay so in session updation deletion and
selection these are the four called dml
selection is comes on a drl data
retrieval language and dml so these are
the four important uh commands you have
to learn from sql and which are again
including join sub queries and
everything
select is a very uh big actual there are
so many options we can use along with
the select command
even joins the subcode is also part of
okay so these are all
database operations how to connect to
the database how we can execute the
queries
from the
python program
and we will able to interact with the
database now our python program is
acting as a client through the coding we
are able to do everything
so without having client application
now with this understanding we should
able to do the data driven testing
so now we know how to get the data from
the table right so once you get the data
we will just pass the data to the
application
there is a data driven testing
so now we will see the data driven
testing how to perform data driven
testing
using database table as a source
okay
now in the previous day we have seen fd
calculator right
now the same application
we are going to test
with the database table data so instead
of getting the data from excel this time
we are getting the data from the table
database table same example again we
will repeat but this time we are going
to use database as a source database
table as a source which contains the
data
now if i just go back to the database
table so we have
one table here
select a star from cal data
so which is already i created this table
myself so the same kind of data whatever
excel sheet yesterday we prepared the
same data which is populated in this
principle rate of interest period one
period to frequency and maturity
but here
we are using this table only for reading
purpose not for writing purpose we are
not going to write any results in the
table
okay why because
in the projects normally what happens is
your database your tables will be
accessed by many people
in your teams okay
so you have to use the data only for
reading purpose not for
modification or not for updation so if
you just let us say if you modify some
column or if you update some data here
that may be impacted for another user
may be that user using this proper data
this data in their project
so there are many scenarios are there so
most of the times
we don't
corrupt the existing data or existing
tables in the database because there are
so many people or do work based on or
depends on the particular tables and
tables data
so don't try to correct the data so
always try to use existing data for
automation testing but where we will
write the results suppose if these
combinations got passed
so at the initial level we will write
the results into console window directly
but
finally we will see i'll show you how to
update the results in the report okay
results will be updated in the report so
we don't again connect to the database
and we don't see results is updated in
the last column or not so we don't do
all these things in the case of database
but excel we have complete control
because excel files we will store only
in the local machine so we have we are
the owners of our excel sheet so we will
able to open the excel files any number
of times so we have full fridge control
on that so we can still write the
results back into the excel it will not
impact anywhere else
but database is not like this so
database is very sensitive component if
you do any small change that may impact
other users or it will impact some other
applications
okay so
just try to use the existing data for
our data-driven testing that's it so now
this is a table i have principal amount
rate of interest period one two
frequency and maturity value so we need
to read this data and then we have to
use it for data driven testing
so now let us go back and
copy the previous example and
accordingly we have to
uh do some changes okay
and here we don't need any utility file
nothing we can directly interact with
the database
now i copying the i copied the same file
and this time i'm using instead of excel
sorry so instead of excel i'm just
trying to use database i'll say db
okay say okay
all right so now let us try to modify
this code
so what are all things we needed so we
will have that code and rest of them we
will remove it okay we don't need that
so currently i want to work with the
database so to work with the database
what are all things we need to have in
this code we don't need excel utilities
we can just remove that import
and
we need to
specify all the configuration we have to
launch our application and we don't need
excel we can also just remove this part
and even we don't need for loop here so
we will write our own for loop
and for now let's have the code like
this and all these things are required
or not
so this is all also not required at all
if you still want it you can still
replace this command so later i will
replace them
and variables i will replace later
and this is required so whatever the
value so we will get from the database
here in this variables we will pass the
variables as usual
and also will the con we will do the
validation but here we do not have excel
we can just remove these two statements
and also we can remove these two because
whatever the statements which are there
related to excel we can just remove them
and then
okay driver working close and time
okay done
so i think time module is also deleted
time is there
okay so that we'll see later so i have
just removed unnecessary code so now
we'll see how we can
get the data from the database so the
first thing
so again go back to our previous code
database operation or select db
operations so what is the first thing we
have to do to get the data from the
table and everything
we have to execute these statements
first we need to import this connector
right so go back and import that
connector
and uh this code is same
so from here to here i'm copying
go back and specify here
okay now observe this so here uh
just a moment and reformatting the code
reformat means it will properly align
the code
reformat the code okay so now if i just
look at this
so till here we already know so we have
launch our application and maximize the
page
and then first of all we need to get the
data from the database and after that we
have to pass the data to the application
right so now what we need to do is
we have established the connection to
the database
and uh what is the table here okay i'll
mention that so table name is
cal data so this is my table name
so i will change it here
so this will execute so where the data
is available now so data is available in
the cursor so from the cursor i will
read each and every row so i'm just
printing it but i don't want to print
here i want to store the data in the
variables so
what i whatever code i have written here
i will move this entire code
into the for loop itself into the for
loop itself
now observe this
so
from the cursor
we get the first row of data what is the
first row of data this is the one
principal amount 2010 to this is the
first record
right so now in the principal amount
what we need to store we have to just
remove them
we don't need all these things because
we don't have an excel and just removing
everything just we need to get the data
from database and store them in these
variables
now we need to get the principle what is
the column number zero so i say row of
zero
row of 0 i'm assigning that value
so from similarly i say row of 1
and this is a row of
and this is a row of 3
and this is row of 4 and what about
maturity value 0 1 2 3 4 5 maturity
value is a 5
so here i'll say row of 5
so now we capture
data from all the columns in the first
row and we have stored in the multiple
variables now the same variable values
we are passing to the application for
every element we are identified each and
every element and as usual we pass them
to the application capture the expected
maturity value again same validation
will start
again expected maturity value actual
maturity value converted into the float
right converted into the float
and then
a validation is started and finally we
click on the clear button and it will
clear and finally we close the
application
so all this code should be part of your
for loop
and once the one round of execution is
completed then what happens from the
cursor it will get another row and again
from that row it will extract all the
data and again pass it to the
application
same thing will repeat multiple times
depends on the data which is having in
the table but now again suppose by
mistake or by somehow some reason if the
connection is not successful
then what happens it will throw the
exception so what i will do now i'll put
a trike block
okay and i will push the entire code
into try block the whole thing i'll push
into the one just give one tab select
everything and click one tab
that's it so that will go to
even including this for loop will be
part of the try block
like this okay now except block should
be there right so here i say accept
block
and connection is not successful then i
will print the message
so here i'll say connection
unsuccessful
[Music]
like this
all right finally i'm closing my browser
so where i'm closing the connection
the connection also we should close
right so where we have to close the
connection we should not close the
connection at the time of repeating the
loop okay so once you completed
everything if i execute the closed
connection here the connection itself is
closed how it will get the data it
cannot right so after closing the driver
here you can close driver not driver
connection connection dot close
sorry
connection
not
close we can use connection close here
okay
so this is how we have to
work with the data-driven testing so let
me just execute and see now right click
and it is not identifying the connection
actually
so because the connection variable which
we created inside the try block
all right so after completion of the fun
loop
[Music]
and it will go up again
okay after execution of for loop
multiple times we have to close the
connection
so it should be
here here it should be why because even
this time dot sleep is also
sorry it is not driver.close it is a
connection.close
and here driver.close
now what happens so in this for loop we
just created all this code so for loopy
started here and end here
and this is not part of the for loop
okay so only these statements are part
of the for loop so until the connection
is open these statements will execute
multiple times after completion of the
for loop after completion of whole for
loop finally connection will close and
then it will come here
so now let us execute and test how it is
going to perform the data driven test
okay now it is launched my application
now you can just look at here
it is reading the data from the database
okay so now it is done so it should
close my page
yeah still it is entering
yeah now you can see so intentionally i
failed the last input so which is uh
actually the input itself is wrong
expected match it value is not this one
actually so that's the reason it's got
failed that is expected
so you can just
try this so this is how we can perform
the data driven testing using database
as a source
so you can have any number of rows you
can have any number of columns it
doesn't matter
okay so
that will not increase that will not
increase your code even if you have used
data in the table that will not increase
your code the same code you can still
use for
data so you can have
a huge data in the table it doesn't
matter so you can still use the same
code
[Music]
okay
so if you still want to reduce the code
what you can do is you can just avoid
creating multiple variables
so instead of that you can directly
specify this row of 0 here
and then row of 1
here and then row of 2 here row of three
here or here row of three row of four
you can directly substitute this
wherever you're passing the data so in
that case another five to six lines code
will be reduced
okay so this is all about
data driven testing using database
so this much is more than enough guys so
apart from this you don't do anything
related to database testing using
selenium
okay people will think this is a
database this is not actually database
testing this is a data driven testing
not a database testing we are not
validating anything in the database
we are not validating anything on the
database we are just returning the data
we are getting the data or we are
fetching the data from the database and
we are using it for data driven testing
that's safer but database testing is
having lot of things we need to do in
the database
so claim is not meant for database
testing remember that
but i have just shown you some basic
operations okay
so print cursor you cannot print because
cursor is a kind of an object it's a
temporary memory which contains the data
okay which will not give you anything so
it's a temporary memory internally
created
so we cannot print the cursor you cannot
directly get the cursor
okay
so remember that
so let me just show you if i print the
cursor what happens
print
cursor okay i'm just printing the cursor
and uh i'll comment these two statements
and see what will happen
because uh this is select a command and
select command will get the data into
the cursor i'm just printing the cursor
execute
what happens it is not printed anything
just mysql cursor is selected star from
orders so it is just executed this query
which is just printed but it will not
give you anything else
so we have to write the looping
statement
by which we will be able to get the data
from the cursor
so this is all about
data driven testing using database
[Music]
okay
that's all for today's session okay i'm
just stopping we will continue tomorrow